así celebran los hinchas en esta higiene
en la ciudad de Buenos Aires El Triunfo
de la selección comandada por Lionel
scaloni un triunfo contundente que les
dio tranquilidad la actitud los polacos
ahí atrás había que hacer un gol más
para dejarla afuera se merecían quedar
afuera por por que estaba muy atrás no
no Argentina de ir para adelante
me gustó el equipo con actitud yendo
para adelante y que se llama así que que
avanza Argentina y mucha confianza para
Argentina es lo que hay que tener fe
mucha fe
no puedo para
además con esta victoria de Argentina se
garantiza el primer lugar de su grupo y
por lo tanto para enfrentar en octavos
de final a la selección de Australia que
en los papeles es un rival relativamente
sencillo relativamente fácil y da la
esperanza de lo mejor poder seguir
avanzando en este campeonato llegar a la
final Y por qué no que argentina se hace
con su tercera copa del mundo